Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Hoy
sacaremos jugo a la clase
porque sé que algunos vienen
para ver si les gustaría tomar otra
clase de filosofía más adelante.
Mucho de lo que hemos
hecho en esta clase
es lo que harían en una
clase de filosofía,
pero una cosa que no hemos hecho tanto
es leer a detalle pasajes
amplios de los textos.
En la clase de hoy quiero que
leamos en grupo, es decir,
yo hablo y ustedes escuchan, no es
realmente leer en grupo.
Ustedes me sonríen y yo leeré
una sección del libro
de Ética de Aristóteles, en
especial el Libro II capítulo 4,
para ubicarlos en las 2 respuestas
que leímos para hoy y que
ejemplifican el tema del curso.
En la primera cuarta o
tercera parte de la clase
vamos a leer este pasaje
de Aristóteles.
Les daré el texto y se los explicaré.
Después, quiero mostrarles
cómo los 2 artículos
que leímos para hoy recogen
porciones muy específicas
y muy precisas del texto
de Aristóteles.
Como ya he mencionado,
analizaremos con detalle
el libro que hemos estado leyendo de
Aristóteles, Ética a Nicómaco.
En especial, hemos
escuchado muchas veces
que Aristóteles afirma que las
virtudes de carácter
se adquieren mediante la habituación.
De la misma forma que aprendemos a
tocar el arpa, tocándola;
nos volvemos justos
actuando como los justos
y valientes actuando como los valientes.
Pero, el mismo Aristóteles reconoce
que esto no puede ser todo
y comienza a debatirlo en el
Libro II, capítulo 4,
que ya leímos 2 veces en esta clase,
hace unas semanas y lo volvimos
a leer para el martes.
Aristóteles observa que
"la gente podría confundirse
cuando decimos que
nos volvemos justos
actuando con justicia
y templados actuando con templanza.
Porque uno podría suponer
que si realizamos acciones
justas o templadas,
en consecuencia, somos
justos o templados".
Aristóteles quiere corregir
un posible error en su afirmación.
En especial, quiere destacar
que para ser justo y templado
es necesario actuar con
justicia y templanza,
pero esa condición no es suficiente.
Aunque para ser justo y templado
es necesario que actuemos como las
personas justas y templadas,
no basta con eso.
Se necesitan también otras cosas.
Hoy vamos a perfeccionar
esa interpretación que ya teníamos.
En las lecturas y en las
clases previas aprendimos
que Aristóteles dice: "para ser
justo, tienes que actuar
como el justo y habituarte a
ese tipo de conducta".
Ahora nos dará otras
condiciones necesarias
para la justicia, la templanza
y las otras virtudes.
Dice: "para que las acciones
se hagan con templanza o justicia,
no basta con que dichas acciones
tengan las cualidades correctas;
además, el agente debe estar
en el estado correcto
cuando las realice".
¿A qué se refiere
Aristóteles con esto?
¿A qué se refiere cuando dice que
para que una acción sea justa,
no basta, no es suficiente,
que la acción tenga las
cualidades correctas?
Sino que además, el agente debe estar
en el estado correcto cuando la realice.
Supongamos que actúo con templanza
solo porque no tengo los
recursos necesarios
para actuar de forma contraria.
Supongamos que la razón por la
que me abstengo de tomar
la leche de chocolate que suele
estar en mi refrigerador
es porque no hay leche en
mi refrigerador.
Supongamos que la razón por la que me
abstengo de ir a una fiesta
el sábado es porque no me han
invitado a ninguna fiesta.
Aristóteles dice
que en ese caso he
actuado con templanza,
pero no lo he hecho estando en
el estado correcto.
O podría intentar dar un objeto
a alguien a quien no le pertenece
y sin querer regresarlo a su
verdadero dueño.
Al hacerlo, regreso el objeto a
su verdadero dueño.
Actúo como lo haría una persona justa.
Pero mis motivos no son los correctos.
Aristóteles dice que
actuan con templanza
solo porque no tienen otra opción,
porque si tuvieran la opción de
actuar sin templanza lo harían;
que si actúan como lo
haría la persona justa
pero sin la intención de ser justos,
solo porque no tienen la información
correcta, su acción no cuenta
como un ejemplo de virtud.
Aristóteles afirma que hay 3
condiciones necesarias
para que un acto justo sea considerado
como un acto justo virtuosamente
o que un acto templado
sea considerado como tal, etc.
Primero, tienen que hacer la acción
sabiendo que están
haciendo algo virtuoso.
Segundo, tienen que decidir
hacer la acción
precisamente porque es virtuosa.
Y tercero, necesitan hacerla
desde "un estado inalterable y firme".
Primero, tienen que estar
en una situación
en la que sepan cuál es
el acto virtuoso.
Segundo, eligen el acto
virtuoso porque es virtuoso.
En tercer lugar, su elección no
puede ser un caso excepcional
en una situación y que no se
presente en otras.
Su elección expresa,
indica y surge de un estado de carácter
que tienen y que persiste en el tiempo.
Les daré unos ejemplos más adelante.
En resumen, Aristóteles dice:
"las acciones justas o templadas
son aquellas que haría
una persona justa o templada",
cuando la persona justa o templada
no solo hace las acciones,
sino que las hace
"de la misma forma que las haría una
persona justa o templada".
Nos deja con esta pregunta:
¿Cómo realiza esas acciones
una persona justa,
templada, valiente o con otras virtudes?
Veamos mediante ejemplo de la valentía
cómo podemos cumplir con las 3
condiciones de Aristóteles.
La primera condición es hacer la
acción conscientemente.
Supongamos que estoy en el
campo de batalla
y sé que hay 2 grupos de soldados:
los valientes y los cobardes.
Estoy completamente convencida
de que no me interesa arriesgar mi vida.
Decido que mi plan es hacer
todo lo que hagan los soldados cobardes.
Me coloco entre el grupo de gente
que pienso que son los soldados cobardes
y hago lo mismo que ellos.
Si resulta que por error
seleccioné un grupo de
soldados valientes
para imitarlos en vez de un
grupo de cobardes,
realizaré lo mismo
que los valientes,
pero no lo haré de la
misma forma que ellos.
Yo pensaba que estaba imitando a
los soldados cobardes,
pero como me confundí
con quiénes eran los cobardes,
he imitado por error
una acción que resultó ser valiente.
Aristóteles dice que:
"No tiene mérito.
No tiene mérito como una
acción virtuosa".
El segundo requisito es que
además de saber
cuál es la acción virtuosa y
cuál es la no virtuosa,
tengo que decidir realizar la
acción porque es virtuosa.
Supongamos que ahora estoy en
una situación similar.
Estoy en el campo de batalla.
Sé cuál es el grupo cobarde
y cuál el valiente,
y decido que quiero obtener
una buena reputación,
por lo tanto, haré lo mismo que
los soldados valientes.
Realizo conscientemente un
acto que es valiente,
pero no lo realizo porque
sea un acto valiente,
si fuera así expresaría una virtud,
si fuera así alcanzaría
ese estado ideal
que Aristóteles destacaba
como importante.
Lo estoy haciendo porque me
interesa conseguir una medalla.
Porque me interesa tener
buena reputación.
Aristóteles dice
que aunque haga lo correcto
conscientemente,
si lo hago con una motivación
incorrecta en mente, no tiene mérito.
En tercer lugar, Aristóteles dice que
para que una acción sea virtuosa,
no basta con que la haga conscientemente
y con la motivación correcta,
también tengo que hacerla de
tal forma que exprese
un rasgo de mi carácter que se
prolongue en el tiempo.
Supongamos que esta vez decido
actuar con valentía
por el hecho de ser valiente,
aunque por lo general, suelo
actuar con cobardía.
Aristóteles dice
que aunque lo haga conscientemente,
pensando que es una "acción valiente"
que realizo por sí misma, si
al hacerlo no expreso
una característica
continua de mi carácter
que me permita hacer esto
normalmente en circunstancias
en las que se requiera valentía,
entonces no tiene mérito.
De hecho, Aristóteles impone
una cuarta condición.
La cuarta condición la explica
en el primer párrafo del
Libro II, capítulo 3.
Y dice así:
"Debemos interpretar el placer
o el dolor de alguien
según sus acciones que son un
síntoma de su estado.
Si alguien se abstiene de
los placeres carnales
y disfruta de la abstinencia, es
una persona templada.
Si sufre, no tiene templanza.
Si se mantiene firme ante
situaciones de miedo
y no siente dolor, es valiente.
Pero si siente dolor, es cobarde".
Volvamos a nuestra lista.
Para que una acción sea considerada
como virtuosa según Aristóteles,
tiene que hacerse sabiendo que
es una acción virtuosa.
Tiene que hacerse porque es una
acción virtuosa en sí misma.
Tiene que hacerse como una
expresión o un resultado
de un rasgo destacado del
carácter propio.
Y tiene que disfrutarse.
Tiene que hacerse
sin sentir que sea una imposición.
Según Aristóteles, una
persona valiente
actúa como una persona valiente de
forma consciente y regular,
por el hecho de ser
valiente y lo disfruta.
El siguiente jueves,
empezaremos a estudiar
una teoría ética que reta
los puntos uno y dos.
Es la teoría ética del
consecuencialismo.
Una versión particular de
ella, el utilitarismo,
que afirma que el valor moral de un acto
no depende del conocimiento
o las intenciones de la persona
que realiza el acto.
Los textos que leímos para hoy,
consideran la 4ª y la 3ª
condición respectivamente.
El texto que leímos de Julia
Annas plantea la pregunta:
¿Qué significa satisfacer la cuarta
condición de Aristóteles?
¿Qué significa?
¿Qué se siente ser un individuo
que disfruta haciendo actos virtuosos?
Y el otro texto que leímos
para hoy de John Doris,
pone en tela de juicio si la idea
de que un acto virtuoso
tiene que venir de un estado
firme e inalterable
presupone algo erróneo sobre
la psicología humana.
Los 2 textos que leímos para hoy,
en realidad vienen directo
de un entendimiento
cuidadoso de lo que sucede
en el Libro II, capítulo 4,
de Ética a Nicómaco.
Ahora voy a pasar a esos
textos, pero antes
quiero asegurarme de que
todos han entendido
de dónde salieron esos 4 requisitos
y lo que añaden a la idea inicial de
que nos volvemos valientes,
haciendo actos valientes; justos,
haciendo actos justos;
y templados, actuando con templanza.
Quiero que les quede claro cómo salió
esto del texto de Aristóteles
que estamos estudiando.
¿Alguna pregunta antes de continuar?
El texto que leímos de Julia Annas,
una erudita de la filosofía
antigua, plantea esta pregunta:
¿cómo sería una buena
persona según Aristóteles?
Es decir, ¿cuál es la fenomenología?,
¿cómo se siente desde el interior
una virtud aristotélica?
Aristóteles nos dijo
que una persona valiente es aquella
que actúa con valentía,
sin sentir dolor, que considera
natural y placentero
actuar como lo hace una
persona virtuosa.
Annas se pregunta: ¿Cómo se
siente eso desde el interior?
Su respuesta es que desde el interior
se siente una especie de
armonía interna
como la que hemos estudiado
en muchas clases
de esta unidad del curso.
"Para una persona virtuosa ejercer la
virtud supone una armonía
de sentimientos y deliberaciones,
y no un sentimiento de
dominar las tendencias".
Es un estado de armonía interna.
Los compromisos
reflexivos, los instintos,
la aprensión del mundo que nos rodea,
los patrones de atención que
tenemos hacia el entorno,
todo eso se une
y no sentimos que haya otra posibilidad.
La persona valiente según la
idea de Aristóteles,
no está en el campo de
batalla pensando:
"Me pregunto qué debería
hacer una persona valiente
y qué debería hacer una cobarde.
Esa acción cobarde es muy tentadora
pero creo que la voy a evitar".
La persona valiente está en
el campo de batalla y,
al igual que la persona de la clase
pasada que ha transformado
una ley normativa en una
ley descriptiva,
siente que no hay otra opción más
que realizar una acción valiente.
En la idea aristotélica,
la persona justa,
cuando se enfrenta a la posibilidad de
devolver la cantidad correcta
o incorrecta de cambio en
la transacción,
no piensa: "Me pregunto si
alguien se daría cuenta
si engaño a mi
compañero.Supongo que no.
Supongo que mejor haré lo correcto".
La persona virtuosa,
según Aristóteles,
ni siquiera contempla la
actividad alternativa.
Por lo tanto,
no siente la necesidad de superar
una tentación alternativa.
No existe el sentimiento de resistirse a
ser llevado en otra dirección.
Existe el sentimiento de que
el mundo le presenta
lo que debe hacer y eso es lo que hace.
Igual que cuando ustedes van a
casa de un amigo a cenar,
supongo que no piensan:
"Qué bonitos candelabros de plata,
¿me los llevo a mi casa o
los dejo aquí?".
El virtuoso aristotélico
sabe lo que es correcto
en todo lo que pudiéramos
considerar un dilema moral.
Aristóteles también
explica qué se siente
estar en un estado en el que estos
sentimientos se separan
y nos arrastran en
distintas direcciones.
Los fragmentos de
Aristóteles que vamos a
leer
para el siguiente martes discuten
precisamente esa cuestión.
¿Cómo es una persona que se tiene que
forzar a sí misma para ser virtuosa?
¿Una persona cuyos instintos
van en otra dirección?
Aristóteles está en la posición y
necesidad de cuestionarse esto
precisamente porque ya nos ha
dicho en el Libro II
cómo se siente estar en
armonía, en un estado virtuoso.
Julia Annas sugiere que
podemos articular esta idea
en un paradigma científico
contemporáneo usando
una idea particular de la psicología
positiva: la idea del flujo.
Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi, un
psicólogo húngaro,
durante los últimos 30
años aproximadamente,
ha entrevistado a gente
destacada en varios dominios
y les ha preguntado qué sienten al
integrarse y comprometerse
totalmente con la actividad
en la que destacan.
Entrevista a compositores,
escaladores, bomberos y músicos,
y les pregunta qué se siente estar
en un estado atlético,
musical, creativo,
en un estado de absorción al criar a
los hijos de forma efectiva,
en cualquier cosa que hagan
bien y que disfruten.
¿Qué se siente estar en ese estado?
Quienes hayan podido ver su
conferencia TED saben que dice
que cuando la atención está
concentrada deliberadamente
en lo que estamos haciendo,
la acción se vive sin esfuerzo.
En un estado de absorción total,
estamos atentos a los sutiles
matices de la experiencia.
Si están jugando baloncesto,
la ubicación del aro, la pelota, su
mano y los otros jugadores
se presentan ahí como una
sola aprensión.
Si están concentrados en un juego
de ajedrez muy absorbente,
tienen una sensibilidad para
valorar la ubicación
de las piezas del tablero.
Si están hablando con
alguien a quien aman
o que les importa, pueden
ver todos los matices
y todas las sutilezas de
esa interacción.
Annas nota que hay 2
características particulares
de la experiencia del flujo que
son realmente fundamentales
en la antigua noción de virtud
de la armonía del alma.
En primer lugar, la actividad de flujo,
la que se realiza con una
integración total,
se vive de forma autotélica.
En realidad, Annas está usando la
terminología de Csikszentmihalyi.
Auto significa: en sí mismo;
télico significa: fin.
Algo autotélico es un fin en sí mismo.
No es un medio para un fin.
Es algo que tiene...
estoy recordando algo de La
República de Platón,
de las primeras páginas de nuestra
primera lectura de tarea.
Es algo que sentimos que tiene
un valor intrínseco.
Es algo que cuando lo hacemos,
no lo consideramos como un medio
para alcanzar otro fin.
Lo consideramos algo que
disfrutamos por sí mismo.
Un pintor que mientras
pinta está pensando
en cuánto podría vender su cuadro,
no se encuentra absorbido por la
acción de pintar en sí misma.
Los atletas que ven su
rendimiento solo en términos
de cuántos puntos obtendrán para
ellos o para su equipo,
no están completamente
absorbidos en la actividad.
Resulta que incluso para las cosas
con valor instrumental,
la forma más eficaz de
hacerlas con excelencia
es dejarnos absorber por ellas
para que sintamos que tienen
valor intrínseco.
Creo que esto nos da una nueva visión
de aquella división triple
que vimos en las primeras
páginas del Libro II
de La República de Platón,
cuando vimos que hay cosas
con valor instrumental,
con valor intrínseco y con ambos.
Nos permite entender que
incluso con las cosas
que solo tienen valor instrumental,
podemos quedarnos absortos de tal forma
que sintamos que tienen un
valor intrínseco.
Y esto, por supuesto, es una
virtud y un vicio.
El artículo más famoso que solo
tiene valor instrumental
es obviamente el dinero.
Tengo que decirles que los billetes
que tienen en sus bolsillos,
considerados como trozos de papel,
no valen más que una
fracción de un centavo.
Pero tienen un valor instrumental
dentro de un sistema
económico de intercambio.
Incluso dentro de ese sistema
económico de intercambio,
solo tienen valor instrumental
porque el dinero por sí
mismo no es útil.
El dinero es útil porque
nos permite comprar
otras cosas que son
útiles por sí mismas:
carros magníficos, buenas comidas,
tiempo para pasar con
nuestros amigos y familia,
oportunidades para visitar otras
partes del mundo, etc.
Podemos comprar todas esas
cosas con dinero.
Pero el dinero en sí únicamente
tiene utilidad instrumental.
Sin embargo, precisamente la
función psicológica humana
que nos permite percibir que algo
con valor instrumental tiene
valor intrínseco,
como anotar una canasta en un
juego de baloncesto,
también nos permite integrarnos
con la experiencia
y tener la sensación de flujo.
Esto puede reorientar nuestra creencia
de que quien muere con más
dinero en su cuenta de banco
de alguna manera ha ganado un juego
cuyos puntos de valor no
eran arbitrarios.
Existe, como casi siempre,
un lado positivo y uno negativo
sobre este hecho de la
psicología humana
de ser capaces de sentir que las cosas
que no tienen valor
intrínseco sí lo tienen.
De hecho, vivir las cosas de
esa manera es una
de las cosas más poderosas e
interesantes que podemos hacer.
Precisamente porque cuando toda
nuestra energía está enfocada
en una actividad, podemos
perdernos en ella.
Hay un sentimiento,
que Csikszentmihalyi
describe maravillosamente
en los últimos cinco minutos
de la conferencia TED
que les pedí ver.
Hay un sentimiento de absorción total,
un sentimiento de naturalidad, un
sentimiento de eliminar
las barreras que hay entre
el yo y el mundo.
Nos convertimos en parte de la escena
en la que experimentamos el flujo.
De hecho, si permitimos
que la conciencia
de nuestra propia identidad
resurja, el flujo se rompe.
Quienes hayan practicado algún deporte,
tocado algún instrumento musical,
participado en una obra
o dado una clase saben que si ven
la escena desde fuera y se
escuchan hay el riesgo de que esto
perturbe su experiencia.
Annas sugiere que la idea de
Aristóteles de la virtud
implica que la virtud
y la realización de la misma fluyan.
Debería sentirse como algo
que nos absorbe.
Debería sentirse como
algo sin reflexión.
Al realizar una acción valiente,
justa, templada, magnánima, espléndida
o con cualquier otra
virtud aristotélica,
el sentimiento de la
experiencia de ese momento
debería ser un sentimiento de estar
haciendo algo inevitable.
El mundo es así
cuando sienten que algo tiene
valor intrínseco,
cuando se sienten completamente
absorbidos y sin preocupaciones.
Csikszentmihalyi continúa explicando
en su trabajo más sistemático
que esto ocurre
porque hay una profunda concordancia
entre el nivel de sus habilidades y el
reto que la actividad les presenta.
Cuando se nos presenta una tarea
que no representa un reto para nosotros
y para la cual tenemos poca habilidad,
experimentamos lo que
Csikszentmihalyi denomina
apatía.
Si hay algo que no me cuesta
mucho trabajo hacer,
pero no soy muy bueno en ello,
tendré poca motivación
para hacerlo con interés.
Si mi nivel de habilidad es bajo y la
tarea es un poco más complicada,
podría preocuparme de no tener
capacidad para hacerla.
Si mi nivel de habilidad es bajo y
el reto es muy difícil,
podría sentir ansiedad.
Si mi nivel de habilidad es moderado
y la actividad representa
poco reto para mí,
sentiré aburrimiento.
No tendré interés en la actividad.
La situación me parecerá tediosa.
Si mi nivel de habilidad es medio
y la actividad representa
un gran reto, podría
sentirme emocionado.
Podría sentirme intrigado.
Podría sentir cierta
motivación para actuar.
Pero los casos que más nos emocionan
son aquellos en los que tenemos
las estrategias necesarias
que nos permiten actuar con
eficacia como agentes.
Recordarán que cuando
leímos el material
de Jonathan Haidt en las últimas
dos clases, él describía
un experimento que se había
realizado en un asilo de ancianos
donde los pacientes tenían la
obligación de cuidar las plantas
del piso o bien alguien más se
hacía cargo de ellas.
Y el nivel de felicidad de
aquellos que participaron
en una actividad productiva
era mucho más alto.
Enfrentarse a algo con habilidad,
poder ser un agente de
fuerza en el mundo
es para los seres humanos una de las
principales fuentes de felicidad.
Si recordamos lo que
hablamos hace unas clases
sobre la importancia de un apego
seguro en la infancia,
una forma de entender lo que
incluye un apego seguro
es un sentimiento de ser un
agente en el mundo.
Si lloran esto provoca que
su cuidador acuda
a satisfacer sus necesidades
y ustedes llegan a sentir que
son un agente efectivo.
Cuando nuestro nivel de
habilidad es alto,
incluso si el nivel del reto es bajo,
sentiremos una especie de
relajación al realizar la
actividad.
Quienes juegan a reventar
burbujas en sus teléfonos
y son buenos en esos juegos
se supone que están
experimentando esto.
Muchas veces tenemos un
nivel de habilidad alto
con una actividad de bajo reto
que nos permite sentir que
estamos relajados.
Cuando tenemos un nivel de
habilidad alto y el reto es medio,
tenemos la sensación de control.
La idea es que si hay algo que
están intentando hacer
y tienen un buen nivel de maestría,
tendrán la sensación de eficacia.
Por último, tenemos una celda sin
descubrir en esta matriz.
Es la celda que nos indica qué pasa
cuando tenemos un nivel alto
de habilidad y una actividad
con un reto alto.
No les va a sorprender saber que es
ahí donde se encuentra el flujo.
Annas sugiere, recurriendo
a Csikszentmihalyi
como una forma de entender
a Aristóteles,
que el sentimiento interior de ser
virtuoso implica estar absorbido
en una actividad que de cierta
manera es un gran reto.
Implica explorar el mundo
para que reconozcan
qué situaciones les exigen
moralmente actuar con habilidad,
de forma natural, sin esfuerzo,
felices y en un estado de armonía,
para ajustarse a lo que el
mundo demanda de ustedes.
Al hacerlo nos integramos
totalmente con una actividad
que sentimos que tiene
valor intrínseco,
el sentimiento de ser un agente distinto
desaparece debido a esa integración.
Ese es el primer artículo
que leímos para hoy.
Un artículo que ofrece una forma de
entender la demanda de Aristóteles
con el vocabulario
de un trabajo contemporáneo
de psicología social.
El segundo texto que leímos para hoy
dice justamente lo contrario.
John Doris, siguiendo a una
cantidad de filósofos
entre los que se incluyen Gilbert
Harman y muchos otros,
sugiere que la psicología
social contemporánea
muestra que la circunstancia
es la principal determinante de la
acción y no el carácter.
Doris afirma que lo que determina
nuestra actitud en una situación,
según la psicología social,
no es algo estable
de nuestro carácter,
no es la tercera condición de
Aristóteles de un estado
que perdure en el tiempo,
sino las características
incidentales de la situación.
En consecuencia, la psicología
moral aristotélica,
en especial en su tercera condición,
exige que cometamos lo que los
psicólogos sociales
denominan error fundamental
de la atribución.
Para explicar el error
fundamental de la atribución
voy a presentarles el estudio
que sirve como ejemplo
del paradigma y muestra
cómo la circunstancia
y no el carácter parece
determinar nuestro comportamiento.
Les presento este estudio
porque es fundamental
dentro de esta bibliografía y
porque en nuestra segunda clase
leímos un fragmento de uno de
sus autores: Batson.
Y cuando lleguemos a la
sección de castigo,
leeremos un texto de su otro
autor: John Darley.
La parábola del buen samaritano,
como sabrán quienes crecieron bajo la
tradición religiosa cristiana,
es una historia que Jesús
cuenta en el libro de Lucas
cuando le preguntan
básicamente lo mismo
que le preguntamos a Platón
y a Aristóteles:
¿Cómo podemos comportarnos de acuerdo
con lo que la moral nos exige?
La historia que Jesús cuenta dice así:
"Bajaba un hombre de
Jerusalén a Jericó
y cayó en manos de unos ladrones
que le quitaron todo, lo golpearon
y lo dejaron medio muerto.
Por casualidad, un sacerdote
iba por el mismo camino.
Al verlo se pasó del otro
lado del camino.
Lo mismo hizo un levita,
cuando lo vio, se pasó del otro lado.
Pero un samaritano que viajaba por ahí,
lo vio y se compadeció de él.
Se acercó a él y le curó sus heridas
con un poco de aceite y vino".
Al parecer es bueno hacer
eso con las heridas.
"Lo montó sobre su propio animal,
lo llevó a una posada y lo cuidó".
Y la historia continúa:
"Le dio dinero al posadero para
que cuidara del hombre".
Y Jesús le dice a la persona que
le pidió la historia:
"Tú también deberías hacer lo mismo".
Si analizamos la historia
del buen samaritano,
deberíamos llegar a reconocer la virtud
de ayudar a un extraño que lo necesita.
Debería parecerles evidente que
entre las exigencias morales
del mundo se contempla que
si alguien herido
está tirado en el camino y
ustedes pueden ayudarlo,
para cumplir con las exigencias de la
moral, deberían detenerse,
acercarse a él y echarle aceite
y vino en sus heridas
o hacer el equivalente
contemporáneo de esto.
El estudio que hicieron Darley y
Batson fue el siguiente.
Tomaron a un grupo de
estudiantes de teología
de Princeton, unos
seminaristas jóvenes.
Aquí pueden verlos con su
ropa de seminaristas.
Y pidieron a algunos de ellos
que prepararan un sermón
basándose en la parábola
del buen samaritano.
Eran estudiantes de teología, se
supone que eran personas
comprometidas con desarrollar un
carácter moral en ellos mismos.
Se les había pedido preparar un sermón
sobre algo que muy claramente destacaba
que si se topan con alguien
que necesita ayuda,
deberían detenerse y ayudarlo.
Después, Batson y Darley
dijeron a un grupo de ellos
que tenían muchísima prisa por
llegar al otro lado del campus
en donde tenían que dar una clase.
A otros no les dijeron esto. A
algunos seminaristas
se les había pedido preparar la
historia del buen samaritano
y a otros se les había pedido
preparar otra historia.
Podrían pensar que si es
cierta la hipótesis
de que lo que determina el
comportamiento es el carácter,
aquellos seminaristas que
habían preparado una clase
sobre el buen samaritano
tendrían más posibilidades
de reconocer las necesidades
morales relacionadas
con toparse con una persona herida.
Y que la cuestión de si iban
tarde o temprano a su clase
no tendría ninguna relación.
Darley y Batson decidieron probar esto.
Pidieron a los seminaristas
que caminaran con ellos hacia el
salón de la otra clase.
Y en el camino había alguien
que necesitaba su ayuda
tirado en la banqueta.
Lo que era indicativo de si los
seminaristas se detenían
a ayudar a este hombre en el camino
no era si habían preparado una
historia acerca del buen samaritano.
Era si tenían prisa para
llegar a su clase.
Muchos de ellos no solo no
ayudaron al hombre,
sino que además le pasaron por
encima y corrieron al auditorio.
Todos hemos pasado por
esto. Si tengo prisa
por ir a recoger a mis hijos y
tengo que orillarme
porque viene una ambulancia
enfrente, me enojo.
¿Por qué? ¿Acaso pienso que la
persona en la ambulancia
merece morir porque yo tengo que
ir a buscar a mis hijos?
No, es porque cuando nuestra
atención está dirigida
hacia una meta externa, nos resulta
muy difícil estar atentos
a las condiciones morales
de una situación.
Y resulta, una y otra vez, que
cuando intentamos determinar
los motivos de una persona para
actuar de una forma determinada,
tenemos la tendencia a sobrevalorar
ciertos rasgos de su carácter,
de su temperamento, y a restar
importancia a las características
de la situación, a las
circunstancias.Podríamos pensar por
ejemplo,
como explica Doris en su documento,
si el hecho de ayudar a alguien
a recoger sus papeles
cuando se le caen al piso depende o no
de algún rasgo del carácter.
¿Son personas que ayudan o no?
Aunque parece que pueden manipular
si la gente está dispuesta a
ayudar simplemente
dejando que encuentren una moneda en
una cabina de teléfonos.
Si no saben lo que es una
cabina de teléfonos,
en la película Matrix hay algunas.
Si ayudan o no
depende de si encuentran una moneda
en la cabina de teléfonos.
En el estudio del buen
samaritano, no están pensando
en ayudar sino que están
pensando en que tienen prisa.
En los experimentos de Milgram, no se
trata de si por lo general
se comportan de una forma o de
otra, sino de si se encuentran
en una circunstancia en la
que se les exige algo.
En los casos de la "suerte
moral" de Vietnam,
no es que estos jóvenes
que fueron a Vietnam
y se encontraron en una
circunstancia tuvieran un
carácter
que los llevó a actuar
como lo hicieron,
dice esta teoría, sino que se
encontraron en esta circunstancia.
Entonces, dice John Doris, la teoría
de Aristóteles es errónea.
Presupone una imagen equivocada
de la psicología humana.
Ya son las 11:20.
Al comienzo de la siguiente clase,
retomaré 2 resultados de la
psicología social que retan,
de cierta manera, la afirmación que Doris
hace en contra de Aristóteles.
Después, continuaremos con nuestra
discusión de la visión contraria
de Aristóteles sobre qué hacer en los
casos de debilidad de la voluntad
y qué estrategias tenemos
disponibles si no satisfacemos
las 4 condiciones de Aristóteles.